[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
dominique bussereau bonjour dominique
bussereau bonjour goût d'être avec nous
président du département de la
charente-maritime président de
l'assemblée des départements de france
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale représentée
par stéphane vernet bonjour stéphane
bonjour qui dirige le bureau parisien du
journal ouest france
on commence bien sûr avec cet hommage
hommage national qui sera rendu ce soir
à samuel pâtit hommage officiel à la
sorbonne en présence d'emmanuel macro
mais aussi hommage dans de nombreuses
villes de france dominique bussereau est
ce que les départements vont prendre une
initiative pour lui rendre hommage
les départements déjà pris beaucoup
d'initiatives depuis ce crime initiative
classique et républicaine comme mettre
les drapeaux en berne
rassemblement à l'intérieur des
bâtiments des départements des
personnels des élus banderole sur nos
bâtiments
et puis à la rentrée scolaire avec les
principaux des collèges puisque nous
avons la responsabilité des collèges
atteindrons dans nos collèges des
initiatives nous avons si souvent
beaucoup les conseils départementaux de
jeunes qui sont des lycéens enfin des
collégiens pardon de 5ème 4ème et nous
allons également travailler avec eux sur
tous les sujets de liberté jean michel
blanquer hier à l'assemblée nationale a
invité tous les élus en fait à se rendre
dans les établissements scolaires à la
rentrée le 2 novembre est ce que est ce
que vous prendrez ce type d'initiative
c'est une très bonne idée j'en ai parlé
hier matin avec jean michel blanquer à
la rencontre état collectivités où il
est accompagné le le premier ministre
oui bien sûr et on va faut que les
aiguilles al faut pas non plus comment
dire faire du cirque il faut que ça se
trouver les moyens avec les profs que ce
soit un vrai dialogue conviennent pas la
représentation mais qu'on puisse
vraiment discuté à l'échangé de les
enfants pour un échange
est ce que vous êtes inquiet quand même
est-ce que vous êtes inquiète cette
rentrée particulièrement dans les
collèges dont vous avez la charge
non pas de la rentrée
même parce que mon la vie la vie va
continuer aller les enfants les
collégiens sont l'insouciance de la rage
professeurs seront certainement plus
inquiet en tout cas les professeurs dans
dans certaines disciplines
voilà c'est plutôt l'état d'esprit des
des enseignants qui mc alger que
j'écoutais ce matin chez vos confrères
d'une grande radio des enseignants qui
disait je ne pourrai plus enseignée
comme avant je vais faire attention à ce
que je vais dire
donc voilà c'est toujours irritant si ça
faisait peur qu'ils nous te censure chez
auto censure je ne pense pas des
enseignants sont des gens courageux mais
voilà une espèce de retenue ç'a toujours
été difficile de faire de la sq ont
appelé quand j'étais enfant collégiens
lycéens l'instruction civique toujours
une manière il matière à dire qu'ils
n'existaient pas t'es fait parfois par
les profs de français
parfois parce d'histoire et géographie
donc 7 va falloir trouver le moyen de de
vivre la citoyenneté et des professeurs
seront en première ligne parce que c'est
eux qui entraîneront naturellement les
les établissements derrière un mot sur
la sécurisation puisque emmanuel macron
et gérald darmanin ont annoncé qu'ils
auraient une sécurisation renforcée des
établissements scolaires dès la rentrée
ce que vous savez comment ça va se
passer pour les collèges est ce que vous
avez déjà des discussions avec le
normand
non et je pense que c'est très difficile
enfin autant on peut dans certains
collèges où il ya déjà des difficultés
des problèmes avoir un équipage de
police nationale ou de police municipale
au moment de l'entrée de la sortie des
cours
et je prends l'exemple de mon
département 51 collège dans la ruralité
on va pas mettre avec eux de gendarmerie
devant chaque collège à l'ennemi qui
n'aurait plus dans les gendarmeries si
on faisait cela
donc il va falloir trouver avec les
parents d'élèves et cetera des mesures
plutôt psychologique c'est pas la
présence d'un képi et qui changera les
choses il faut trouver un environnement
psychologique qui permettent aux parents
aux enfants aux enseignants de venir
l'esprit tranquille et libre dans un
établissement d'enseignement à propos de
mesures un premier train de décision
sera prise ce matin en conseil des
ministres
emmanuel macron s'est exprimé hier en
direct de la préfecture de bobigny est
ce que vous pensez qu'il a kill aquila
qui l'a vraiment avec le gouvernement
l'exécutif est ce qu'ils ont vraiment
pris la mesure de la situation et ce
qu'ils prennent les choses à bras le
corps vous savez après chaque attentat
dans notre pays il ya eu depuis près de
300 morts depuis quelques années en
incluant les graves événements du
bataclan et des terrasses parisiennes
à chaque événement il ya une réaction
le problème c'est que la réelle celle ci
est adaptée elle et elle est bonne pour
vous saouler là toutes les réactions
sont nécessaires et utiles
il ne faut pas simplement faire
scrogneugneu il faut que ça dure
le changement je vais vous dire il est
il est dans les têtes
il ya une partie de la gauche socialiste
bien pensante qui avait une vision un
peu lénifiantes des problèmes
d'immigration et des problèmes de
sécurité
et comme c'est ce sont ces le corps
enseignant très souvent marqués
politiquement à gauche et c'est pas un
reproche c'est une tradition
républicaine dans notre pays qu'il a de
l'entregent république qui est touchée
en son coeur ça peut faire bouger un
certain nombre d'hommes et de femmes que
jusqu'à présent avait une vision que la
sécurité s'était la droite c'était voilà
c'était l'autoritarisme ça peut faire
évoluer les esprits et avoir une espèce
de communion de toutes les forces
politiques à l'exception naturellement
la récupération outrancière du
rassemblement national pour faire bouger
la société et sur les mesures elle-même
qui s'annonce est ce qu'on est dans le
scrogneugneu comme vous dites ou est ce
que ce sera est ce que ce sera écoutez
le contrôle des réseaux sociaux est une
vraie question le ce qui est arrivé à la
loi via de par la volonté du conseil
constitutionnel pose problème j'ai
l'habitude de dire que si les réseaux
sociaux avaient existé pendant
l'occupation nazie pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale peu près deux tiers des
français auraient été dénoncées de
courageusement et anonymement à la
gestapo à la milice donc
c'est vraiment la question de l'anonymat
sur les réseaux sociaux qui pose
problème je sors le les réseaux sociaux
ça permet dans des pays autoritaires on
voit ce qui se passe en chine on voit ce
qui se passe en russie une véritable
liberté un espace de liberté de
démocratie mais l'anonymat
aidés des horreurs que l'on peut lire
sur les réseaux sociaux en france
nécessite mon avis à une véritable
réflexion collective
au delà des réseaux sociaux il faut
modifier la constitution pour l'adapter
à la lutte contre l'islamisme radical je
ne le pense pas honnêtement vous savez
le réflexe de tous les gouvernements y
compris ceux auxquels j'ai appartenu
quand il ya un problème c'est de faire
une loi
moi je dis au contraire quand il ya un
problème c'est d'appliquer déjà mieux
les lois existantes
c'est à dire par exemple la loi sur le
séparatisme elle n'a pas elle n'a pas
lieu d'être a n'est pas nécessaire pour
vous elle est une étape supplémentaire
mais je veux dire on va passer un temps
fou parlement pour la voter elle va pas
changer fondamentalement les choses qui
est important c'est l'état d'esprit
c'est que le gouvernement avec les
forces de sécurité l'ensemble des forces
politiques du pays est en vue
d'appliquer l'esprit de la loi
séparatiste mais rajouter des taxes à
des textes comme tous les gouvernements
le font depuis depuis le début de la
vème république
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit la
solution adaptée on se fait plaisir on
donne le sentiment l'opinion qu'on
réagit en réalité si on appliquait déjà
tous les textes existants on s'en
porterait certainement mais il est plus
que probable que ce qui vient de se
passer ne mène à durcir le contenu de la
loi sur sur le séparatisme
vraisemblablement c'est au législateur
deux dandys travailler au sénat et à
l'assemblée nationale
c'est cet état d'esprit enfin ce petit
jeune homme pakistanais qui vient
commettre un attentat devant devant les
anciens locaux de charlie c'est un
mineur non accompagné qui était arrivé
dans le département de l'oise ou du val
d'oise je ne sais plus exactement les
travailleurs sociaux l'avait refusée
c'est pas des policiers des gendarmes à
ce sont les travailleurs sociaux
ce département et puis un juge dans sa
liberté naturellement d'agir a prononcé
le jugement inverse
ce garçon ce garçon à conflans sainte
honorine
ce criminel il a commencé par parvenir
demander le droit d'asile ça a été
refusé et la cour nationale d'asile
adil inverse donc c'est là où se situe
le problème c'est qu'à un moment ou un
autre je vais pas en cause en justice un
c'est que dans les instances d'appel on
a toujours un jugement qui par nature ou
par idéologie est plutôt favorable et
qui entraîne des difficultés ce et puis
après quand ce garçon reste sur le
territoire ce qu'on ait des moyens de
reconduire ce qu'on a des avions les
policiers de l'air et des frontières
pour renvoyer dans leur pays d'origine
un certain nombre de deux garçons qui
n'ont rien à faire chez nous c'est très
compliqué je pense que le gouvernement
est devant une situation extrêmement
dernièrement sur les élus locaux est ce
que les élus locaux ils ont suffisamment
de moyens pour lutter contre le
communautarisme est ce qu'ils sont
suffisamment protégés pour les élus
locaux ont le moyen d'agir tant qu'on
est dans des communes à dimension
humaine chaque camp le maire connaît
tous les habitants de sa commune ça
arrive à peu près jusqu'à 5000 habitants
où les élus connaissent à peu près où
savent quand il voit quelqu'un où il
habite qui est la famille etc
là on arrive à régler les problèmes pas
seulement de communautarisme et prennent
de violence
des problèmes de maltraitance et c'est
un des problèmes de la vie quotidienne
les locaux peuvent le faire dès condé
dans des très grandes villes avaient été
très grand quartier ça devient
extrêmement difficile plus que les élus
locaux ne connaissent pas ce moment là
leur population le maire d'une ville de
cent mille habitants
voilà il connaît un certain nombre de
réseaux ans a connu connais pas tous les
habitants donc c'est extrêmement
difficile mais vous avez raison c'est le
bon niveau moi j'ai toujours pour en
terminer avec lui rassemblement national
quand je vois tous ces personnes dans
nos communes rurales qui sont venus
habiter là parce que les villes sont
trop chers les villes ne sont pas là à
la hauteur de leurs moyens financiers
mais qui vivent seuls qui ne participent
à la vie du village et cetera si on veut
éviter qu'ils votent front national
c'est pas en votant tous les quinze
jours des textes sécuritaires c'est que
le maire et les élus locaux les prennent
en main les ramène dans la vie
collective les invite à l'apéro les
invite à venir au rassemblement du
troisième âge les invite à venir à la
science de théâtre et les remettre dans
la communauté nationale est justement là
parler des élus locaux et des dossiers
des départements hier avait lieu la
conférence des territoires nouvelle
version la rencontre état collectivité
est ce que l a été utile cette rencontre
pour vous devenu busway ce qu'elle a
répondu à vos attentes
une rencontre c'est toujours utile la
conférence nationale du territoire cave
instauré les gouvernements précédents
gouvernements d'edouard philippe était
un échec tel échec qu'à la fin on n'y
avait plus parce que ça ne servait à
rien on était 150
tout le monde voulait prendre la parole
en deux heures c'était le le brouhaha
complément sortait rien le premier
ministre quel sexe à essayer d'encadrer
l'exercice dont nous étions moins
nombreux il n'y avait pas
enfin voilà tout le monde pouvait
prendre la parole et s'exprimer
correctement
après si vous voulez les problèmes
techniques qui sont les nôtres des
problèmes financiers
les problèmes de décentralisation les
problèmes sociaux par le raja
certainement du rsa on les a évoqués
mais que la part du discours consacré la
crise après l'assassinât de sa mère
pattie à la crise
duco vide a fait que le temps réservé
aux questions des collectivités
territoriales a malheureusement été un
peu court
parce que nous étions dévoré par une
actualité politique économique sociale
et et de faits divers extrêmement grave
mais du coup il a répondu à vos attentes
le premier ministre est ce qu a eu des
annonces et des informations venant voit
lui aucune annonce
a priori ce n'était pas le but de la
manoeuvre donc je ne mets pas en cause
naturellement le le premier ministre
simplement des négociations se
poursuivent par exemple en ce moment
entre nous les départements gouvernement
il ya des huiliers négociations avec les
régions qui l ont abouti déjà et des
discussions avec les communautés et des
collectivités locales communes et
intercommunalités mais sap a été un
moment de règlement des questions c'est
un peu dommage vraiment pas encore qu'on
soit encore moins nombreux et que ce
qu'on se consacre uniquement sujet mais
on peut pas empêcher un premier ministre
de venir nous parler de la situation de
la sécurité en france après le crime de
confiance et honorine et on était aussi
attentifs à ce que nous disait olivier
ferrand sur l'évolution de la pandémie
et naturellement nous prenons toute
notre part dans l'effort de la société
pour lutter contre cette mallette un
dernier mois avant de rentrer dans les
dossiers avec stéphanie à une prochaine
rencontre de prévu vous a donné une pro
du premier ministre vous avez qu'il y en
aurait deux parents donc l'année 2020 se
termine je suppose que la prochaine sera
en 2021 selon le calendrier électoral
car vous savez bien qu'il ya un doute
actuellement qui s'est instaurée dans
les esprits est ce que les élections
départementales et régionales prévues au
mois de mars 2021 auront bien lieu en
mars 2021
non pas pour des questions de magouilles
politiques mais pour des questions liées
à l'épidémie aux conditions de campagne
aux conditions de vote
donc je pense que tout ça jouera nature
est calibré calories position sur le
sujet moi je suis un républicain
classique donc
favorable au maintien des dates prévues
telles que prévues par la loi
si le gouvernement estime à un moment
précis que les conditions ne sont pas
réunies comme il l'a estimé après le
premier tour des municipales en mars
dernier en déplaçant le deuxième tour en
juin naturellement nous nous plierons à
la volonté du gouvernement et du
parlement puisqu'il faudra voter à une
loi naturellement pour repousser ses
bastides décalage
il devait y avoir vous seriez plutôt
favorable à un vote au mois de juin par
exemple les papas calédonie plus tôt
possible le plus tôt possible ça il ya
l'élection présidentielle suivie
d'action d'initiative au printemps en
donc il faut à mon avis décoré au
maximum ces élections locales
départementales et régionales des
élections politiques du printemps 2000
wenger pour en revenir aux difficultés
récurrentes des collectivités et
notamment des départements que vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure donc ils n'ont
pas été réglés lors de la rencontre état
collectivités il ya la question du
financement notamment des missions que
l'état confie au département où est ce
que vous en êtes sur le rsa que vous
vouliez évoqué par exemple le rsa c'est
une crainte terrible toujours c'est oui
et soul et 2015 2016 on était dans une
situation très difficile pour les
départements combien d'argent ils vous
manqués par exemple à une ou aujourd'hui
en 2020 il va nous manquer pour le rsa
peu près 5 milliards d'euros et environ
3 milliards pour la pour le reste c'est
à dire la location des personnes âgées
la paix à l'apa et puis la prestation de
compensation du handicap
pourquoi parce que et pardon 2015 2016
on était très mal puis ça s'est arrangé
parce que la situation économique du
pays s'est améliorée quand la situation
que le mec du pays s'améliore le nombre
de bénéficiaires du rsa baisse
automatique là en l'occurrence
maintenant c'est tout l'inversé
maintenant c'est tout l'inversé nous
avons des licenciements nous avons des
plans sociaux massifs nous avons des
artisans commerçants restaurateurs
cafetiers qui viennent s'inscrire au rsa
qui ont fermé déjà après des événements
du printemps noir malheureusement
d'autres au fil des mois avait des
chiffres sur l'augmentation dû écouter
elle est très divers selon lui
appartenant ça va
2 5 6 7 % en plus dans les départements
les moins touchés jusqu'à 15-20 % dans
les départements les plus touchés
je crois qu'on peut dire actuellement
que par rapport à l'an dernier en
moyenne nationale
nous sommes au moins à plus de 10% mais
ouais j'ai discuté avec mes collègues de
la mayenne et d'ille-et-vilaine pourquoi
ici de ces départements non parce que tu
as volé par tous parce qu'ils sont dans
la licence dans la zone de diffusion de
votre quotidien régional préféré ouest
france parce que son département
français où il ya le moins de chômage
moins de demandeurs d'emploi bien dans
ces départements l'augmentation d'un
mois à l'autre à sont plus les mêmes
chiffres c'est pas une augmentation
annuelle peut atteindre plus de 20%
donc on va avoir une grosse difficulté à
financer le rsa et risque de jouer ce
qu'on appelle l'effet ciseau c'est à
dire que le gouvernement nous demande à
juste titre de participer à la relance
donc d'investir dans des routes dans des
collèges dans la rénovation thermique
dans tout ce que l'on veut le la fibre
optique etc
et si nos dépenses de fonctionnement
augmentent et qu'elles ne sont pas
compensées par l'état pour le rsa nous
allons pouvoir à ne pas pouvoir
participer à la relance par manque de
moyens financiers et d'autant dominique
bussereau qui est un amendement au
budget qui vous met en colère les
départements qui bénéficie d'une part de
tva en compensation de la perte de la
taxe foncière sauf que le gouvernement
veut vous reprendre le surplus de tva
l'année prochaine vous vous le dénoncer
on a posé la question hier à jacqueline
gourault écouter ce qu'elle vous réponds
c'est simplement qu'il y à un phénomène
de ressaut entre une année où la baisse
de la tva a beaucoup baissé et l'autre
où elle a beaucoup augmenté et donc nous
allons bien sûr comme prévu laissé au
département et je ne soit dit en passant
mais il n'y a pas de laisser ce milieu
il est partout non mais c'est pas fini
laissez moi on va laisser aux
départements la hausse
je dirais traditionnel de tva c'est à
dire à peu près 3% et leurs sauts bien
évidemment vous on va leur prendre et je
dis pas c'est normal c'est un gros saut
on va pas comment dire dans ces jeunes
mamans pour finir aux 10 milliards on en
a besoin de mecs ou la nuit
la crise non la hausse de bonheur dans
la mer ça ne coûte rien faut que
dominique bussereau disent aussi ce
qu'on propose à côté c'est à dire il ya
ceux que je viens d'exprimer et puis il
ya un fonds de stabilisation ou un fonds
d'urgence on l'appelle con comme on veut
qu'il va être aussi versé au département
et dont nous allons discuter complet
désaccord avec jacqueline gourault
naturellement le fonds dont elles
parlent ces 115 millions le chiffre dont
je vous ai parlé de l'augmentation
possible du rsa en 2021 pour les
départements c'est à notre avis de
l'ordre au minimum d'un milliard d'euros
qu'est ce qui se passe dans cette
affaire c'est vraiment la technocratie
au pouvoir on nous supprime à nous les
départements ain impôts que nous
percevions c'est de ce qu'on appelle le
foncier bâti c'est à vous avez une
maison un appartement payé un impôt qui
est partagé entre les communes
départements de serre nous supprime
cette part pour la dalle est au bloc
communal et on nous dit vous vous la
compenser par la tva nous râlons parce
que d'un côté c'était un appeau nous
avions la responsabilité de l'autre
c'est une compensation dont seul l'état
assume les responsabilités donc ça nous
semblait déjà malsain et on s'est dit le
gouvernement s'est dit chouette on va
les coincer on va leur donner moins
d'argent
sauf que pas de bol ils pensent qu'en
2021 il y aura un ressaut je souhaite
mais ça voudrait dire que la situation
économique s'améliore qui a une reprise
de l'activité et donc de plus de tva et
asseoir nadia non non non alors là mais
quand c'est à votre avantage ça marche
pas quand c'est à votre désavantage ça
marche comme c'est à votre avantage ça
marche pas hélas ce milliard dont nous
aurions besoin pour le rsa en
particulier et pas seulement dans le
bercy nous dit on va vous l'enlever et
donc que nous sommes en complet
désaccord chez d'ailleurs appelé cet
amendement est gelée dit olivier dussopt
up qui en est l'auteur à ses services
mais qui le portent politiquement c'est
un amendement tout qualifiant de
scélérat
qu'est ce que vous allez faire râler
discuter proposer
nous avons des discussions qui dès
demain s'engage continue de avec
jacqueline gourault et je l'espère avec
bercy parce qu'en réalité c'est bercy
qui tient les clés du coffre
comme toujours dans la république
mais supprimée au sénat on imagine ça je
l'espère bien sûr mais si vous voulez on
peut pas on peut pas avoir un système
dans lequel les départements qui vont se
prendre le choc social
le choc de pauvreté en pleine phase qui
sont prêts l'assumé parce que telle est
l'ambition naturellement ne sont pas
aidées par l'état et sortir cet
amendement qui concerne des recettes de
2021 donc arrêter la loi de finances
2022 maintenant c'est une véritable
provocation et donc je les dis au
premier ministre je les dis à jacqueline
gourault j'en ai dit de manière très
très courtoise et red wings of il nous
livre on va trouver une solution pour
compenser plutôt que de trouver une
solution pour compenser il eût mieux
valu ne pas faire voter cet amendement à
l'assemblée nationale il y à 48 heures
parmi les autres dossiers compliqués à
gérer pour les départements il ya suivi
des mineurs étrangers non accompagnés ou
est-ce que vous en êtes comment évoluent
les chiffres est ce que les états vous
êtes suffisamment sur ces questions je
vous ai fait le point tout à l'heure sur
l'évolution du rsa optionnel au cours de
l'année 2020 c'est à peu près la même
chose c'est-à-dire que nous avions une
montée du mineur non accompagné pour vos
téléspectateurs mineurs non accompagnés
sont 99 % des garçons qui arrivent
principalement d'afrique subsaharienne
qui arrive parfois de l'est du pakistan
et d'une partie de l'est de l'europe en
difficulté et dont les augmenter si tous
les départements en fait qu'ils arrivent
comprenait des parties garino de manière
illégale par des réseaux de passeurs mdp
réseaux de passeurs extrêmement
organisés et nous nous devons nous nous
devons de les recevoir parce qu'ils sont
mineurs et donc premier problème qui se
pose la minorité nous en parlions tout à
l'heure à propos de du crime de du siège
de de charlie hebdo il faut évaluer leur
minorité
quand vous avez un gaillard qui fait un
mètre 90 et 90 kg qui vous dit qu'il a
13 ans on voit tout de suite dans
d'autres cas c'est plus difficile les
prélèvements au se font l'objet de
débats certains pensent qu'ils sont
valables techniquement d'autres médecins
disent les exactement inverse
donc une fois que nous avons ces garçons
qui viennent de ces zones
nous devons une fois leur minorité
accepté souvent souvent c'est une
véritable immigration légale c'est à
dire une famille quelque part en guinée
décide d'envoyer le plus doué de ses
enfants le plus résistant le plus
bagarreur part en terme de d'accrocher
la vie pour aller travailler en france
et comme il ne peut pas rentrer par
l'émigration légale profil qui les moins
de 18 ans pour l'envoyer parce qu'on
sait qu'après 18 ans il pourra rester
donc une forme d'immigration illégale
mais la charte de l'onu nous oblige à
les accueillir et combien combien les
estimez vous cette année les estime
actuellement sur le sol national
en métropole de l'ordre de 40 milles et
nous estimons le coût pour les
départements à deux milliards par an ces
garçons nous devons les nourrir nous
devons les rassurer
y a pas d'augmentation significative il
ya eu un stop il y avait un stop complet
un stop un stop complet pendant la crise
pendant le coït parce que les frontières
étaient verrouillées n'ai pas de vol
il n'y avait pas de train qui arrivait
d'italie ou d'espagne et cetera
et puis depuis la fin du confinement
nationale c'est cela remonte absolument
donc il faut vraiment traiter ce
problème faut le traiter
financièrement faut le traiter
humainement mais pour l'instant c'est
une charge énorme pour les départements
que nous faisons des tas nous aide assez
peu juste un peu pour l'évaluation et
les deux premières périodes de séjour et
c'est un problème d'immigration
clandestine et moi je vois chez moi la
rochelle le lundi matin il arrive des
voitures les dépose une petite fiche
pacifié parfois parfois avec le nom des
travailleurs sociaux
donc c'est pas ce sont pas ces garçons
qui ont eux mêmes d'abord et ça ça veut
dire qu'ils arrivent par des réseaux de
passeurs il encore c'est le travail de
l'état qui n'est pas facile de
démanteler ces réseaux de passeurs et
merci beaucoup dominique bussereau merci
d'avoir été avec nos erreurs on retrouve
dans 15 jours pour le congrès des
départements absolument à la rochelle à
la rochelle si tout va bien si les
choses vont moins bien le franc
visioconférence si la charente maritime
continuent d'être préservé nous ferons
un congrès réel avec un millier de
d'élus départementaux avec jean castex
et avec jean castex en clôture sera
l'occasion dû passer nos messages en
espérant d'ici là nos négociations
auront progressé
merci dominique bisson regarde la une de
ouest france stéphane de ouest france ce
matin
consacré bien sûr à l'hommage à sa mère
pattie après le choc l'enquète progresse
c'est à la une de votre journal merci
messieurs d'avoir été avec nous ce matin